my daughter is gonna get to go made some
baby calves today that my aunt just
birthed yes Jessica doesn't is still
saying the things that make you go huh
it has exactly why we love her she's
also a fashion mobile and a devoted mom
who makes it all work and she's showing
us how only we joined Jessica on the
road as her mini-me daughter made her
runway debut
[Music]
hey it's justice Simpson we are in my
hometown of Waco Texas I am so happy
that you get to experience this life
with me it's not going well at 36 years
old she's worth a reported 150 million
dollars she's got two adorable kids
three-year-old ace and her look-alike
five-year-old daughter Maxwell her
husband Derek Johnson well we all
remember when they posted their almost
not-safe-for-work Fifty Shades photos
and on top of all that she's got this
body and these legs so yep when Jessica
invited us to do a little ride-along
with her we said yes please right now
all I can think about is
my Nana it's exciting all my family's
here my daughter's gonna be in a runway
show
like what but how did Jessica evolve
from the girl who said this is this
chicken what I have her is fish
I know its tune of it it says chicken by
the sea to the happily married working
mom head of the $1,000,000,000 Jessica
Simpson Collection fashion Empire
we played a little watcher secret game
to try to find out how Jess does it all
so first up what's her secret to big
hair Texas what's the secret always
feeling great about your body sex what's
the secret to wearing a low-cut dress
perfectly blue Chevron and what's the
secret to a sexy marriage you give that
away or I'll go and I'll have a sexy
marriage like Jessica is back in the
recording studio making new music six
years after a last album she's in studio
every week juggling that and launching
new fashion so what are the words of
wisdom she wants to pass on to her kids
you can do anything that you believe in
anything that you want to do and
that's what makes you want to do it she
is absolutely right you know what I
remember leading up to the Dukes of
Hazzard
all we talked about was those daisy
dukes right there
[Music]